では よろしくお願いします
まあ今日はこのテーマで
諦めるのはまだ早いというテーマで話をさせていただきます
で 諦めるのはまだ今大失敗したらどうしようかということで
まあ一応 大逆転と思うことに矛盾があるんです
で 例えばね 失敗して その失敗を大逆転にすると
そんなすごい能力があるんだったらね
まあ少々間違いあるかもしれませんだけど
大失敗はないと思いますけどね
だからそういう微妙なところ
微妙なところ まあどうでもいいことではないんです
我々にも大きな問題あります
いろいろ失敗しちゃうと
もう悔しくなっちゃって
大逆転 大逆転してやるぞとかね
それっていうのはありえない話で
もともと大失敗したんだからね
まあもう能力ないに決まってるし
その上くだらんことを妄想したりするんだからね
さらに失敗するにはもう決まってるパターンです
ですから あまり軽々しく考えない方がいいんです
だから 大逆転という考え方にも矛盾があるんです
大成功したいという観念が大失敗の原因になってしまうんです
初めから我々も大成功したいと
と思うんだったら もう決まって大失敗になるんです
その考え方に問題があるんです
何かやるする 大成功したさせたいと
あの限って能力ない人はそう思うんです
夢ばっかり見ているんです
能力ある人にとっては別にとったことない普通な流れなんですね
自分が淡々となんとか仕事をする
そういうそのまま流れていく
能力ない人はあれこれと夢を見るんですね
ですから まあ大体そう考える人は大失敗はする
ですから 妄想 観念 夢 期待などをやめて
具体的にアプローチしましょうということで
ですから 我々は人生に対して妄想やら
あれやこれやで 夢とかね
期待とか そういうあらゆる観念をね
やめてしまって すごく淡々と具体的に
自分の周りのことを観察すればそれだけなんですよ
人生っていうのは 自分の足元
周りを見ないんですね
頭の中だけで生きてみようとする
それってありえないんですよ
頭の中の回転する概念というのはすごくいいと思っていること自体もう完璧な間違いなんです
すごく非論理的で非科学的なんです
なぜならば 頭の中っていうのはもう何でも回転させすることできるんでしょうし
ただ電気あっちこっち歩き回っているだけのことです
それと実際の生き方っていうのはほとんど関係ないんです
頭にいかに無意味なくだらないことを想像できるかということは
この漫画の世界を見るとわかるでしょうね
アニメーションとかね
これまた日本が世界一でしょうね
で あらゆるもう漫画の世界でも怪獣は出るは
いろんなものは出てくるでしょうね
で それっていうのは実際の世界であるわけじゃないんです
しかし 頭だけなら何でもそういうくだらんことは考えられるし
それでさらに頭が異常で病気だったら
もっとよく明確にそういういらんことを考えることはできるでしょうし
だから頭は病気で 腕が上手だったら漫画家になるんです
だから結局はそういう人々はどうやって収入を得て儲かっているかというと
実際身についている腕なんですよ
実際にすごいプロで もうものすごく速くタンタンタンと絵を描けるんですよ
すごい恐ろしいスピードで
それにはその人々はものすごく苦労して訓練するんです
特に漫画の場合は キャラクターの形も描くたびに変わっちゃうと
もう漫画になりませんだからね
だから何十万も同じものを描くんですけど
またいろいろ微妙にの差でアニメーションにするんだからね
だからこれはものすごい大した技術でしょうし
それで実際あり得もしない怪獣がしっかりと喋ったり動いたり
その上感情まで表したりして
で だからといって描くたびに怪獣の形が変わるんだったらね
これはもう一貫性がなくなっちゃってわからなくなるんですね
だから そういう人々が実際どこで生きているのかというと
自分が実際に獲得している能力なんです
妄想できるんだから 誰にでも妄想できるでしょ
でも誰でも売れる売れる漫画家になれないでしょうね
だから 頭で何でも妄想できるんだっていうことはよく覚えておいて
生活しないと 頭で何を妄想したっても
生きる上では関係ないんです
成功して生きる上では
自分の肉体で何ができるのかということなんですよ
実際に具体的に だから夢なんかはもうとっても危険なんです
余計な期待なんかはとっても危険なんです
もう徹底的に 具体的に
合理的に生きてなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 最後にこの夢期待という観念というのはやめた方がもう人生は成功するんです
そういうわけで 結論で話は終了します
で それだけなんです 今日は
で すべての現象は無常です
変化します これもすぐ忘れるんです
これは自分と一体になった心理にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
それには瞑想実践しなくちゃできないんだけどね
もう自分がいるというこの感覚がいつでも固定概念を作っちゃうんですね
自分がいるということは仮定しちゃうと
他のものもあるということになるんです
実際 ここに自分自身という固定したものはない
もうただの変化するプロセスでしょうと
例えば怒っても私が怒ったんじゃなくて
何か耳に音が入っちゃって
そこはもう処理したところで
もう拒絶反応が起きただけのことなんです
そこで別の音を聞くと
あの拒絶反応がなくなっちゃう
別の反応が出てくる 単なる外から触れる情報に
こちら反応して反応して変わっていくだけ
自分っていうのはないんですね
これ経験しちゃうと もう無常っていうのはわかったことになるんです
でない限りは 我々はもう頭では聞いたことがあるんだけど
すべて変わるんだぞとかね
でもいつでもそうでない
という無意識な気持ちで生きているんです
変わるはずがないんだと
例えば 皆様は世の中でいろんな計画を立てたりするでしょうね
そのどんな計画 計画でも見てください
ある変化しない何か何かをまず選定して
それに対象して何を変化させるかということを考えているんです
それが計画なんです だから変化しないということを前提でなければ
計画は成り立たないんです
そういうわけで 誰がどんな計画を立てても
100%うまくいくはずがないんです
イラクに爆弾を落とした時は
イラクはもう何の能力もない軍事力もない国ですとよく知っていて
それで強引にものすごい強烈に爆弾をもう何千トンも落としちゃえば
まあこちらのものだと
で その計画でただ 100%うまくいくためには
イラクは全く変わらない状態でいなくちゃいけないんです
無気力で軍事力もなく
攻撃もできなくて あまりにも爆弾降ってくるんだからね
身動きもできない状態である
それは変わらない それに対して私たちはもう朝から晩まで 24時間
2  3週間かけて爆弾を落とすと
爆弾 1個でも まあ大体まあ1,000万
100 万  500 万かかりますから
それは日本やら他の国々から取るぞと
計画はそのことで しかし
イラクは絶対変わらない
安定しているものだというところはちょっとおかしいんですね
そちらもその瞬間 その瞬間変わる現象なんですよ
だから計画はうまくいかなかった
一人もアメリカ兵隊は死ななかったと自慢したんですけど
十分死んでいただきましたからね
戦争をするとお互い様
死ぬんだから  それは変わらなかったんです
お釈迦様おっしゃっている法則は戦いなさいよ
互い死ぬんだよと だから戦争では勝利がないんだと
どちらでも負けを受けるんだと
負けでしょうね だから
これはわかりやすい例で
我々日常の生活の中でもそういうふうに小さなそういう風ではないんだけど
似たような小さな小さな計画を立てるんですよ
計画を立てる場合は ある一個が変わらないという
選定で別なものを変える
それが計画なんです だから変えることは
この変わらないことに対処させるんですね
でも この選定した変わらないものも変わっちゃうんです
どんな計画にしたっても
考えてみてください  例えば服を作っている人がいて
まあいろんな色でもういろんなデザインで服を作っちゃえば
まあもう 1個売っちゃえばかなりもう儲かりますからと
利益はもう10万ぐらいあるんだぞと
それだったら自分に能力あるんだから
それをフルに活かしてもういっぱい作ってやると
それでもう一回売っちゃえば10万だったら
あるいはモデルをサンプルを売ってしまえば
もう億だからね じゃあ 10個ぐらい作っちゃえばもう文句なしと
そこは計画で しかし 彼が
その人が安定した変わらない一つ前提としてあるんですよ
売れるんだと みんな同じスピードで同じパターンで買う
それは変わらないということは前提であって
こちらで計画を立てると
しかし それはありえないんです
買う側も変化するんです
だから計画通りにはいかないんですね
そういうわけで この無常ということが変わるんだということはすごい大胆な真理で
なかなかそんなシンプルな真理なのにシンプルじゃないんですけど
シンプルな真理のに とにかくそれに逆らおうとするんですね
逆らおうとするたびに失敗する
ありえないんです 事実に逆らえませんだから
法則に真理に逆らえないんです
だから人間というのは空気を吸うのは当たり前の法則でしょうね
私は反対だと じゃあ反対してみてください
死にますよ 決して逆らえません
あるいは私は絶対的な神様を信じているんだから
神様をもういることはみんなに
この何でしたっけ？無神教の人々に
思い知らせてやるぞと
と思って 神様は作って育てるんだから
私は今日からは何も食べませんよと
飲み物を取りませんが
その代わりに神様にお願いしておくんだぞと
養ってくれる？そんなケース一つもないでしょうに
死にますよ だからこの法則には逆らえません
他宗教で思っている偉大なる神様さえも
法則には逆らえません
で あらゆる聖書たくさんありますから
なんであれこれで条件つけてるの？あいつはもう力がないんです
喋ってるだけで 結局はこうすればこうなる
こうすればこうなる こうすればこうなるという話なんです
まあそういう曖昧な もう何の真理も発見していない人々の妄想概念で語るところでも
まあ法則に逆らうことはできないんです
そういうわけで 本当の唯一な法則は無常ということ
ある人はもう薬を飲まなくても病気が治りましたとかいうのは
普遍的な法則じゃないんです
そのある方の病気が治療しなくて治ったならば
そちらに何か原因があるんであって
それに乗っちゃって じゃあ私も治療をやめますよと言ったら
自分がそれで死ぬ可能性はあります
でも 誰にも適用する 誰にも逆らえない法則のまあ一つ
二つしかないんですよ
宇宙の法則はたった二つしかないんです
で 一つは無常 流動的で流れるということ
もう一つは因縁ということで
たったそれだけ そういうわけで
あの これ無視するんだからこそ
我々はいかなるところでも失敗するんです
お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
このサッベーサンカーアニッチャーということが真理なんですね
従って変わらないものはありません
変えないものはありませんと言ってはいけません
変わらないものはありませんと言っても
そういうところも気をつけてほしい
何でも変えてやるぞと
それはできません 何でも変わりますが
何でも変えてやるということはできません
すごい微妙ですよ 微妙ですけど
意味はものすごい大胆です
あ 何でも変わるんだ では私は何でも変えてやるぞと言う人
おかしいでしょうに この建物は必ず変わるでしょうに
だったら変えてみてください
それはできないでしょうね
変化は因縁によるものです
この 2番目の真理 それしか世の中で真理ないんです
だからこの今日の講演にしたっても
物質全てを勉強することになるんです
変わるんですけど いい加減変わるんじゃなくて
因縁によって行儀よく変わっていくんです
蕾は花になるんですけど
実にはなりません 行儀が悪いんです
蕾は永遠に蕾でいるかというと
それはとんでもない話で
ありえないんです 変わるんです
変わるんだけど 花に変わるんです
だから無茶苦茶じゃないんです
変わるといっても すべて変わるんだけど
行儀よく姿勢も正しくしっかりと変わっていくんです
だから予測したい人に予測できる
頭がいい人には 変わるんだけど
どのように変わるかということは一応あるんだから
女の子が生まれてきて
ある日突然男の子になったっていう
そこまでは変わりませんよ
女の赤ちゃんが生まれたら
その瞬間から変わりますけど
どのように変わるのかということはもう決まっているというかね
そのパターンがあるんです
計画はその人にできます
因と縁を変えられるなら果も変わる
そこで物事を変えたければ
この因と縁を変えるんです
因というのは原因 縁というのは条件
だから蕾は花になるのはもう
避けられないんですよ
でも今日花咲いちゃったら困ると
お客さんが来るのは明後日だと
明後日花が咲いて満開になってほしいと言うとできますよ
その花が早く咲く条件
因縁 ちょこっと変えておく
それをすごく冷やしておくとかね
あるいは太陽の光が当たらないように暗いところに置いておくとかね
そうすると蕾がなんか勘違いしてまだ夜だとかね
朝までもう待ってるぞとかね
そう勘違いしちゃって
それでお客さんが来る前の日は置いておくんです
それで花が今日はって咲くんですよ
そういうことで  2日ぐらいは遅らせることはできます
そこは見事に成功する計画なんです
しかし 蕾はいきなり実にすることはもうできません
ということで 我々は物事を変えるということは因縁を変えるということだけなんです
そういうことで結論でしたからね
まあ失敗しても 次の次の条件を希望通りに変えることはできます
だから大失敗であろうか
小さな失敗であろうか
まあちゃんと因果法則と無常ということをわかっておけば
もう問題はないんです
条件だけちょこちょこといじっておけば変わるんです
うん